حيث اعلنت هيئه شؤون الاسرى والمحررين
الفلسطينيه استشهاد الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
في مستشفى اساف هارفي الاسرائيلي نتيجته
تدهوري حالته الصحيه جراء اصابته بسرطان
الرئه منذ اكثر من عام وقد حملت الهيئه
حكومه الاحتلال المسؤوليه الكامله عن وفاه
ابو حميد بسبب ما وصفته بسياسه الاهبال
الطبيه المتعمد التي تتبعها اداره سجون
الاحتلال مع الاسرى وقال مراسل الجزيره
الى اضراب عاما نفذ في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتله وشلى جوانب الحياه العامه
ورسميه والفلسطينيه كافه
وقد يتشحت الاراضي الفلسطينيه بالسواد
حداد على استشهاد الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
واعلنت محافظات عده الاضراب الشامل تمديدا
لسياسه الاهمال من قبل الاحتلال وذكرت
وسائل الاعلام المحليه ان الاضراب الشامله
محافظات رام الله والبيره والخليل وبيت
لحم ونابلس والقوس المحتله كما وجهت
دعواته لتنظيم مسيرات الحاشده حدادا على
استشهاده
عائله الشهيد ناصر ابو حميد اكلت من جهتها
انها ستظل في حاله حداد مستمره الى ان
يتحرك الجسد ابنها ومعه سائر جثامين شهداء
المحتجزه في مقابر الارقام وداخلتها
ثلاجات الاحتلال
وفي اولى ردود الفعل الفلسطيني حمل رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد الشياه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مسؤوليه استشهاد الاسير ناصر
ابو حميد في المعتقل الاسرائيلي
اللجنه الدوليه الاحمر الى التدخل من اجل
افراج عن الاسره المرضى وكبار السن
والاسيرات والاطفال من سجون الاحتلال اما
الخارجيه الفرصانيه فقالتنا حركه دوريه
متواصل للفرجه عثمان الاسير الشهيد ناصر
ابو حميد كي يتسلى
موالاته فرح كذلك حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه
ستعطي لاحتلال المسؤوليه الكامله عن
تداعيات استشهاد الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
وطالبت الحركه المؤسسه الحقوقيه
والانسانيه بالوقوف الى جانب الاسرى
اذا قال رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس
اسماعيل هنيه الى استشهاد الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد بعد معاناه طويله من مرض السرطان هو
جريمه جديده ضد الشعب الفلسطيني ولن تمر
دون عقاب واكد هنيه في بيان صحفي ان
المقاومه لن تتوالى عن السير في كل الدروب
من اجل تحرير الجميع الاسرى وتحرير كل شبر
من فلسطين وفق تعبيره
اكلت فصائل العامه الوطنيه والاسلامي في
غزه انا جريمه اغتيال الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد
دون حساب وداعه الفصائل الفلسطينيه خلال
وقفه احتجاجيه امام مقر اللجنه الدوليه
لصليب الاحمر في غزه داعش الشعب الفلسطيني
العام والثوره في وجه الاحتلال
المحاور كافه
الفصائل الحديده العام في القطاع لمده
ثلاثه ايام ودعت الخروج في مسيره غاضبه في
قطاع غزه بجريمه اغتيال ناصر ابو حميد
محمل الاحتلال الصهيوني
المسؤوليه الكامله عن اغتيال الاسير ونؤكد
على ان سياسه الاهمال الطبي
والقتل البطيء المتبعه بحق اسرار الابطال
لن تمر دون ثمن وعقارب
[موسيقى]